[MUSIC]
>> Good morning
>> Good morning.
>> It's great to see you all,
you look fantastic.
Good job even with the masks
on you still look fantastic.
It's been a long time, I hope you're
really excited about the day.
It's been I don't know for me,
fantastic to have you all in person.
>> Are you ready?
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Okay, stand up and go, good luck.
[MUSIC]
>> I think my squad is a bunch of killers,
I think they're going to
absolutely dominate.
I'm going to be honest, I think they did
extremely well in the roleplays they've
always taken them seriously.
They've had no problem jumping into
character, and they're going to do great.
>> Yeah, a great learning experience for
them to deal with people
in the real world.
>> I think uncertainty is just something
to predict now, so I don't know,
whatever happens, it'll work out.
>> Well, I think there
are moments that I always get at
the GSB is how smart the students are.
The students are very smart, I mean,
so they were given the case,
just an hour before we met, and
they already had their facts all lined up.
They already had their reasoning and
their preferred choice, and
arguments, pros and cons.
>> We spent a lot of time thinking through
negotiation tactics, and also working
together as a squad, to think through who
has the right skills for which situation.
>> Not really sure what to expect,
i'm also really looking forward to
meeting the alums, and
seeing what feedback they have.
>> We heard it one of
the students was we realized,
as we get to the end of this
interaction with the alums.
That a board meeting is not
about presenting to the board,
it's about engaging with the board.
>> They're going to do great,
they've been practicing for this,
not only all this quarter all their life.
>> And I was calculating that if on
average, each judge had about 20 years of
experience, there's over a century
of experience in that room.
And so, as Tony Robbins said, if you can
just take that experience of, say 100
years, and learn it all in one afternoon,
well think of how much time you've saved.
>> I think just really this being a nice
culminating experience with my squat,
especially after our last session,
I was really focused on feedback.
>> I'm feeling fantastic, it's really
exciting to see all of our squad, and
the folks who are coming
in first year at the GSB,
culminating today it's going to
be a great experience.
>> I just feel like I took away
maybe more than they even did.
>> We have a great spot, I'm very
confident that we're going to crush it.
[LAUGH]
>> I would say our biggest thing is that
feedback is a gift ,and we've been
really practicing being open and
frank about feedback, and
providing constructive feedback.
So I think being able to learn and improve
over the course of the leadership labs,
activity has been really rewarding.
And I'm excited to see how my team will
improve over, the course of the challenge.
>> I am excited, i'm nervous,
don't really know what to expect, but
it should be a good time.
>> My goal for the day, I'm about to
find out by being myself, cheerleader.
Feeling good, feeling energized,
I'm waiting for
that coffee to open up, but
pretty excited for the day.
>> I feel like our squad has worked a lot
together, to really do hone in on our
leadership skills, and so
I'm curious, see how it all pans out.
>> I never had to have these
kinds of discussions before, so
this is a great experience that you guys
are exposing, first quarter NBA ones too.
>> Well, I think it's going to be
a cool day with some cool people.
I'm excited to meet the judges, and
to hopefully have a cool executive
challenge and learn something.
>> To actually try different
approaches different,
takes in a lab environment, right?
It's not your real life, so
if they succeed, they learn what works,
if they fail, fail beautifully [LAUGH]
they fail in a very safe environment.
>> I'm excited to hang out with my
squad [LAUGH], they're awesome.
>> I'm excited to be on TV, hi mom.
>> 17 again [LAUGH]
>> 13,
whoa, celebrate.
>> We're team A team, we're team A team,
[LAUGH] some one else say something.
>> 18.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Good luck.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> We actually bought champagne,
I had a shipment from Napa
that arrived yesterday, so
we're going to celebrate really well.
[MUSIC]